si vous pensez que les super-héros sont
des super-héros la prédit for Spee est
là
super vilain City et faite pour toi de
bien un
homme d'aujourd'hui
super vilain
et le glutenator
le plus grand vilain est super village
aide-moi à enlever ce truc tout de suite
monsieur dépêche-toi
je suis venu m'inscrire c'est le rêve de
ma vie je
découvre quel type d'homme de marque
vous êtes
j'arrive pas à croire que vous êtes mon
mentor
voici mon équipe les meilleurs hommes de
main de classe 3 de la ville homme de
main aujourd'hui super vilain demain
accroche-toi à tes à cette serpillière
d'accord c'est vous le boss
regardez-moi ça
mot de passe Mot de passe
[Musique]
correct
tu dois apprendre à te servir de tes
pouvoirs on se remet au travail
habitants de super village GT je pars à
la conquête du monde en commençant par
cette illuminable tu dois l'arrêter tu
t'échapperas pas
pourquoi tu es d'une bande d'homme
demain inutile parce que je suis un
homme de main
on n'est pas des super-héros on n'est
pas des Super Vilains non plus on est
une famille ça va être un jeu d'enfant
une famille d'homme de marque
seconde